[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and oranges the new
black has just wrapped up its final
season on Netflix the send-off is
bittersweet and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the finale as
well as giving my thoughts on it
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch the
7th season yet then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my ending explain breakdown of orange is
the new black orange is the new black
arguably had one of the most complex
final seasons of a show ever and
throughout there were a lot of ups and
downs especially in the show's finale
that wrapped up pretty much all of the
loose ends and gave closure to our
favorite characters the opening packed a
huge punch with a sink Tiffani being
taken out of the prison once and for all
in a body bag
tiffany has been a fan favorite from the
start in this iconic image let you know
instantly that this finale was gonna
have several gut punches throughout one
of the major ones comes with tasty who's
unable to clear her name
after being framed for murder though she
is initially suicidal she finds a reason
to live after becoming a lecturer in
prison and she inspires and drives many
to go on and get their diplomas which
gives her a purpose to live once more
this hopeful aesthetic is throughout the
season and the finale is as much about
losing hope as it is finding it once
more through discovering a new purpose
Niki goes on a journey and ends up
helping detainees contact their loved
ones on the outside to show that they
have hope and that there will be more to
life one day than simply being locked up
this is also mirrored with Piper and
Alex whose relationship struggled due to
the fact that Alex is transferred Piper
who managed to get out on an early
release finds her newfound freedom
difficult to deal with
due to the fact she's being
institutionalized and season 7 was about
her coming to terms with the fact that
order often kept her in line and without
it she feels unable to truly live their
life she wishes - Alex tells Piper to
move on with their life and though it
seems like she made this
season shows that they have rekindled
their relationship when Piper visits her
once more to show that she's found hope
that after all of this is over the two
compete together this is probably the
highlight of the entire show and it
cements that these characters no matter
how bleak it gets always have an
opportunity right around the corner and
that will give them a reason to live and
go on even warden Ward who's fired in
the very last episode is still presented
with something new that could perhaps
change the way she values life and thus
Season seven is as much about reform as
it is rebirth blanket also represents
this as she's able to overturn her
initial conviction and becomes a free
woman after suffering four years at the
hands of incarceration she flies to
Mexico to reunite with the love of her
life and it's the perfect happy ending
that pretty much feels like she's gone
off into the sunset to begin something
special relationships have always made
up the foundation of the show a Monica
who's reunited with her mother Cindy
shows that we can grow together as one
no matter the barriers are put between
us as long as there is love there even
Carla who perhaps is one of the most
devastating turns in the finale still
deep down has the hope that out there
there's something for her and we'll be
able to go on due to the opportunity
that could present itself to me this
summarizes the true meaning of the show
and pretty much highlights the real
subtext to it life is all about pushing
forward and now it will throw challenges
our way there will always be hope that
one day we will overcome them either by
ourselves or together with someone else
it's a really touching send-off and
overall the piece shows that though we
may be separated eventually we will all
come together in one form or another to
find happiness no matter how dark things
ahead look it's one of the main reasons
that I think season seven truly is a
classic and orange is the new black goes
out on a memorable no that it's the
perfect example of why it's one of
Netflix's most popular programs at one
point this was a flagship show for the
platform
and it's safe to say that this will be
remembered as a great piece of
television
due to its consistency and overall
message Orange will forever be the new
black and even though life is full of
tragedy there will always be hope of
happiness one day and that's my summary
of the final season of orange is a new
black
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the finale and if you agree with me
or have a completely
and take command below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of this week's other big
television release the boys from Amazon
which would be linked at the end in it I
go over the full season and give my
thoughts and where the show could go so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you'd like to
see more of my thoughts on movies TV
shows and games then you can come chat
to me on Twitter a definition whitey
it's the best place to talk to me and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on things
I discuss so make sure you head over
there after this I also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the orange is the new black
finale in the comment section below the
winner will be announced on August the
10th and the blue arrow be shipped out
from them to ever get surprised it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]